ncg asks what does one do when you feel  you have unique content but not tapping  into the right audience or not gaining  visibility Nicola this is where you  start looking yourself in the mirror and  deciding if you have business  development chops this notion that you  have the greatest content and it's not  finding its audience is romantic at  worst and audacious at best right and so  like to me what you need to look at is  are you capable of also building  audience for your content or you just  the content provider and do you need a  partner who can go out and help you do  that or have you just lost all sense of  reality and your stuff is just average  oh crap wait subscribe to do I need  subscriptions because I can't push this  many right hooks in social so subscribe